talk about I'm gonna cry SADS
hi I'm Maisie Williams and I play Arya
Stark Arya as the daughter of the Lord
but she doesn't really want to be she
doesn't get very well with the sister
and I think her mother hopes that she
would be a little bit more like her
sister I guess her father kind of feels
like that to lecture below um but Ari is
a little different to everyone else
she's always dreamt of being a warrior
and going off into battle this is no toy
be careful you don't cut yourself
she's closest to her brother Jon Snow
you're so skinny so were you they've
always clicked I think they've both
always felt a little bit like they don't
fit John for more obvious reasons than
Arya first listen sticking with the
pointy end I know which sin to use
they've always found an unlikely
friendship in each other I don't need a
girl as no.1 Ari decides no I don't want
to play this game anymore a girl is bias
top of Winterfell and I'm going home
it's back to crossing names off her list
and she doesn't slow down when she gets
home you're not one of mine oh yeah no
didn't think so Jim pretty she murders
Walder Frey in the best way possible
bakes his sons into a pie they weren't
easy to carve
the last thing you're ever going to see
is a stark smiling down at you as you
die she heads north back to Winterfell
when she has that reunion with Sansa
feels really odd what suits you lady
Stark
John left you in charge he did she's the
lady of Winterfell and I think Arya
wants to just dig a little deeper into
what that means to her and she sees
little holes in sanz's bravado she's
spent the last period of time analyzing
people that she's just kind of like a
human like sect now and I think she sees
a lot of holes in our and in Sansa she
meets Brown again and he's been given a
Valyrian steel dagger by Littlefinger
and he doesn't need it so he gets it
Arya Arya finds out that Sansa did write
a letter that confirms all of those
thoughts when she was younger that Sansa
was behind her father's death and little
does she know that she's being played by
little finger and little finger has them
both where he wants them just when it
looks like Ares about to be put on trial
for false charges we stand accused of
murder you stand accused of treason how
do you answer these charges Lord Baelish
[Music]
they end up killing nettle finger Brito
from that moment if they wanted to make
a conscious decision to really see a
change in Aria I never could have
survived what you survived you would
have you're the strongest person I know
I believe that's the nicest thing you've
ever said to me don't get used to it
still very strange and annoying and the
end of season seven you really see a
newfound respect for Sansa and Arya I
kind of wanted to continue that in the
new season hey everybody it's Charlie so
you asked me to do videos for these
other Game of Thrones promos this is
just Maisie Williams talking about
Aria's journey so far highlighting some
of her biggest moment for shadowing what
herb reunion with Jon Snow is going to
be like giving some context as to what
was going on during season seven and
what she's going to be like or how she's
going to be different during season
eight we get a whole bunch of new stuff
to break down there's a new round of
that Song of Ice and Fire book giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video so when she talks about Jon Snow
for all the things that the show has
changed from the books her relationship
with Jon Snow versus the other star
children is pretty faithful they both
feel like outsiders Jon is literally an
outsider because he's supposed to be a
bastard Whirlies grew up thinking that
he was a bastard and being treated like
he was a bastard particularly by their
mother Catelyn Stark that's one of the
core foundations of his character so
it'll inform a lot of the decisions he
makes and what happens between him and
Daenerys during season eight we'll talk
more about that when we actually start
getting episodes but for Arya she's more
of a metaphorical outsider just because
she doesn't want to conform to
expectations for highborn ladies like
Sansa Jon and Arya were closest to each
other growing up that's why their
reunion is going to be so much more
impactful than Jon's reunion with Sansa
because while there have been other
stark reunions since Jon was reunited
with Sansa during season six John really
hasn't run into any of the other
children besides Theon and I don't know
if you could consider him one of the
stark children the reason why the
reunion with Sansa was an emotional
moment was just because both of them had
escaped death one in a literal case like
Jon literally came
from death in salsa escaped living death
with Ramsey like the Bolton's needed her
to gain Winterfell so he couldn't kill
her he could have tortured her for the
rest of her life which is almost worse
than death Aria in John's reunion is the
first stark child reunion of two of them
that were actually really close with
each other like Sansa Orie and bran were
all reunited it was a very emotional
moment but none of those children were
close to each other like Arya wasn't
close to bran
Sansa wasn't close to Arya Sansa wasn't
close to bran that's why John and arias
reunion during season eight is probably
gonna be one of my favorite nice ones
there couple bad or notorious reunions
that I'm looking forward to as well like
Jaime Lannister being reunited with a
brand like oh the last time we met I
pushed you out a window well I'm the
three-eyed Raven now and I can see
everything that you've ever done your
entire life there are no secrets you can
keep from me anymore Maisie Williams
talks a little bit about her plot with
Sansa how Arya was questioning her for
most of the season trying to poke holes
in her facade trying to find out if she
was lying to her about things the funny
thing about that is that other
characters also said that they were
annoyed with Sansa like kid Harrington
even in real life said that he was
annoyed with the Sansa character during
his season 8 promo I'll link that at the
end of this because it actually is
pretty funny but Maisie Williams
clarifies what was actually going on in
these moments because there were so many
arguments that happened in the comments
after those episodes and even though the
producers came out later there were
still people that were confused about
when Littlefinger was playing the Starks
and when the Starks started to play
Littlefinger just to be clear there was
a scene during episode 6 where
Littlefinger finally suggests to Sansa
that Arya means to kill her
that's when Sansa pumped the brakes and
started questioning Littlefinger's
motives she and Arya go together to see
bran and access the CCTV archive that
Isaac Hempstead right described himself
as so that's happening in episode 6
after this moment here before episode 7
picks up so that when you pick up at
episode 7 at that mock trial that was
really when things turd and they started
playing him
so almost the entire season that Arya
was at Winterfell starting around
episode 4 she was after Sansa if you
were really frustrated with that plot I
think the reason why they
included that because it did feel very
unnecessary because they marketed the
season using that salsa voiceover and
the very first trailer
the lone wolf dies the pack survives
that was a quote from Ned Stark in the
books so as a fan I don't think there
was ever any point that we actually
thought that Arya would legitimately try
to kill Sansa so it just made their
whole plot feel completely unnecessary
but I think they wanted to give them a
common enemy and pay off little fingers
series aren't going back to season one
and earlier getting revenge for making
her Mary Ramsay for manipulating her and
revenge for betraying Ned Stark to the
Lannisters Maisie Williams is now saying
going into season eight Arya is
different because she respects Sansa and
she's actually going to try and be
supportive of her however there is a
really big problem that is coming to
Winterfell in Episode one named Jon and
Daenerys they've already revealed that
salsa is gonna be the flat tire in this
situation so if aria is gonna try and be
supportive of Sansa but while she might
respect her she loves Jon Snow
unconditionally so I think automatically
if there were ever any kind of argument
or family drama REO would always side
with Jon over Sansa so it'll be fun to
see how that affects their relationship
given that she's trying to be so
supportive of Sansa in season eight the
other big complication for Orion season
8 is the return of Gendry so she has all
these things coming back to her that
made her human like the the girl that
you saw during season 1 before she
became this faceless person Terminator
so a big part of her arc during season
eight will be in reconciling those two
halves but she also has her list she
mentions it several times during this
season 8 promo
Arya is a list it was the big sticking
point when she was in Braavos training
as a faceless person she could not leave
the list behind which I think will come
back around in season 8 she'll continue
to cross names off the list don't forget
that Cersei is a name on Arya's list
that she will probably end up crossing
off in the finale but speaking about
finales and big moments she doesn't
spend a lot of time talking about the
Valyrian dagger Isaac Hempstead right
says some really interesting stuff about
how brand sensed the importance of the
dagger and that it was important that
Arya have it but Maisie Williams doesn't
seem to know anything about that that
might just be because the producers feel
like Arya wouldn't have foresight or she
doesn't have the knowledge that bran has
so it's not important for her character
to know
what the dagger is for only that she's
going to use it but post all your Aria
theories in the comments below I'll do
more character promos in the next week
or two they dropped a whole bunch of
them congratulations to the giveaway
winner from my last big video Michael
Blaise please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your details
click here to watch the Jon Snow season
8 promo and click here for the brand
Stark season 8 promo
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight